Obtaining and aggregating health data presents many domain specific challenges.
Think back to earlier in the course when we discussed
HIPAA and the protection of patient privacy as
well as obtaining patient permissions for the use of
their data unless it is fully de-Identified.
However, depending on the use case,
fool the identification can substantially reduce the value of the data.
Where genomic data is involved,
the identification may not be feasible if that data is to have any research value.
Even with patient permissions,
all the interoperability issues we discussed
earlier can be impediments to aggregating data for research.
These include the reluctance of hospitals and
other sources of clinical data to lose control of it.
Without semantic interoperability, and it is still rare,
data from multiple sources must often be normalized
to a standard model to be useful for analysis.
Earlier, John Duke discussed
the Federated Research Model and the use of
the Observational Medical Outcomes Partnership,
OMOP, data model across a research network to solve many of these issues.
We will talk with John about the tools to analyze data that is in the OMOP model.